rosa gálvez usted es una gran defensora
del medio ambiente se trabaja desde hace
mucho tiempo en este ámbito y
recientemente publicó un artículo en el
que hablaba de la reducción del plástico
como una manera de propulsar el medio
ambiente pero también la economía
canadiense resumen nos brevemente cuál
fue el objetivo de la escritura de este
artículo y hacia dónde quiere que vaya
está esta política canadiense este tipo
de políticas canadienses y yo a la base
a la base es verdaderamente orientar al
consumidor para que reduzca la cantidad
de basura que produce cada año cuando
justamente cuando justamente comparamos
entre latinoamérica y canadá por ejemplo
el canadiense promedio va a votar 4
kilos de basura por día en los países
latinoamericanos hablamos de 1.8 2.8 el
máximo es 2.8 entonces hay una
diferencia abismal en la manera de
consumir el plástico aparecido ya hace
seis décadas
y es producto de la petroquímica y hay
una industria de la sobre embalaje no
entonces nos han convencido de que de
que por causas sanitarias y por causas
este de higiene y por causas de estética
estética había que poner empaquetar
empaquetamiento a todos los productos no
entonces eso es con justificación y
otras veces sin justificación eso hay
que decirlo efectivamente hay productos
que se necesitan ser como la carne no
pero hay otras cosas que no
necesariamente necesita estar
completamente empaquetadas pero lo que
ha originado es esta sobreproducción de
plástico y este plástico que solamente
10% es reciclado entonces se encuentra
en los ríos en los suelos y en el mar y
viene a producir este gran parche esta
gran superficie que es
del tamaño de quebec que está flotando
en el pacífico entre hawai y california
no entonces hay que darse cuenta de que
este plástico no se degrada a pesar de
que hay hay hay industrias que dan te
han proclamado que hay biodegrabilidad
no no es tanto así y puede tomarse
cientos de años antes de degradarse y
produciendo un impacto sobre la
biodiversidad sobre la fauna de los
océanos y este que no escucha de la de
las ballenas que que mueren con plástico
en el estómago de los de hasta en el
ártico ha encontrado pájaros del ártico
con plástico en el estómago entonces es
un desperdicio es un desperdicio de la
del recurso natural que es el petróleo
que está al inicio no al gas el el
petróleo y el gas
cuesta en términos de la declaración
hasta si de todo a todo nivel entonces
había que hacer algo
y es con mucho interés que yo veo de
cuando en inglaterra ha tomado una
iniciativa muy importante porque pienso
que fue la bbc y con su primer el
documental yo en el planeta earth que
mostró no imágenes de esta situación y
después de ahí ha habido como un efecto
de bola de nieve y entonces muchos
países y ciudades han decidido de de
acabar con esta con esta desperdicio
entonces en este artículo que usted dice
es que en realidad la gente el público
el ciudadano medio puede hacer mucho al
exigir que haya menos plástico tal vez
en sus en sus supermercados o aún no
comprar los productos con demasiado
plástico con demasiado empaquetados pues
absolutamente absolutamente ese es una
cuestión del de la de la información de
la educación del consumidor para que él
sepa y tenga conciencia de que lo que
pasa si por ejemplo la china que recibía
mucho de nuestro plástico para reciclar
ha decidido que no lo recibe más porque
ellos también tienen su propio plástico
a reciclar y entonces qué ha pasado
entonces ahorita hay una crisis en la
industria del reciclado en todo canadá
porque ya está alternativa de enviar
nuestro plástico usado para reciclado
allá en china ya no es más entonces todo
se está poniendo un poco la soga al
cuello y bueno es interesante porque
para personas como yo que leemos esto
desde hace muchos años entonces una cosa
simplemente que que iba a pasar no iba a
pasar de solamente saber cuándo va a
pasar cuando va a pasar pero ya pasó
entonces estamos aquí y entonces yo
quiero hacer la aclaración de que mucha
gente me puede decir a ustedes invertía
ambientalista ecologista pero yo te digo
no yo simplemente soy muy tierra tierra
y es
de alguna manera trato de ver las cosas
globalmente y la ecuación global que es
que hay un costo para cada nivel hay un
costo en dos partes pueden ser más
eficientes y para justamente tener una
mejor calidad de vida
y eso no debe ser pensado de que es
ahora que es verde ecologísta o
socialista si no es simplemente sentido
común ciudad pena ciudadana comprometida
con el planeta exactamente porque todo
el mundo quiere lo mismo claro que el
agua limpia aire limpio o un trabajo y
una educación para sus hijos no todo el
mundo quiere eso entonces cuando al
final tenemos todos este mismo objetivo
es simplemente de ver cómo llegamos a
ese objetivo
rosa gálvez usted es senador
independiente en el senado canadiense
muchas gracias de nada paloma y para que
nos volvemos a hablar